bonsoir Guillaume cané bonsoir bienvenue
en apparté merci ravi de vous accueillir
de nouveau ben merci dans cet espace
vous vous souvenez de deux trois trucs
ah ben je me rappelle bien maintenant
j'ai l'impression de d'être un peu chez
vous résidenceaire oua oua bon on s'est
installé un peu plus loin que Paris
intramuros on a fait quelques kilomètres
on est dans le 21e arrondissement vous
reconnaissez évidemment les planches
vous y étiez il y a pas si longtemps
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a proposé cette
vue le festival du film de d'oville bien
sûr euh président du jury surtout en
précisant euh c'était là il y a quelques
semaines c'est c'est c'est comment ce
rôle-là c'était super j'ai passé un
moment merveilleux d'abord c'était assez
étonnant euh de de de de de voir des
films sans rien savoir au préalable en
fait c'est vrai que moi j'ai demandé en
plus au aux membres du jury d'ailleurs
je je j'en profite pour les saluer j'ai
j'ai eu un un groupe des membres
formidables on a on a constitué un
groupe vraiment super on s'est très très
bien entendu et euh et je leurais
proposé de rien savoir avant de voir les
films de pas
connaître pas savoir si céit un
réalisateur une réalisatrice voilà euh
de de de de de savoir si voilà de pas
rien connaître sur l'histoire savoir si
c'est un premier ou un un 2uxè ou un trè
film et du coup ça nous permettait
vraiment de découvrir euh les films de
manière totalement neutre alors que
quand on va au cinéma en général quand
on va voir un film on sait un peu on a
vu une bande annonce on se fait un peu
une idée on a une envie ou pas et donc
du coup c'est vrai que là c'est c'était
vraiment génial et et puis c'était très
agréable de parler de film avec des gens
formidables qui ont beaucoup de talent
qui sont tous différents avec des
univers assez différents et et et
c'était très intéressant et j'imagine
aussi très stimulant pour vous qui être
qui êtes un un un perfectionniste
quelqu'un de très exigeant pointu euh
vous regardez ça aussi avec avec un
triple regard celui d'acteur évidemment
de réalisateur aussi de voir c'est
intéressant aussi de voir comment un
film parle à certaines personnes et pas
à d'autres et pour quelle raison et et
pourquoi on est plus touché que que que
d'autres et c'est c'est toujours c'est
toujours très très agréable quoi alors
je vous installe au comptoir parce que
du coup comme ça on a la vue sur les
planches de d'auville et puis l'exigeant
et le perfectionniste va que vous êtes
va pouvoir va pouvoir juger de la
qualité de ce CR exactement ça cétait
pour vous amadouer est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est bien joué ou pas ouais
mais vous êtes hyper perfectionniste
donc comme vous savez le faire et
apparemment vous le maîtrisez très très
bien est très bon il faut me donner une
note bon j'avoue c'est pas moi qui l'ai
fait non franchement il est très très
bon c'est vrai ouais ouais franchement
je mets un vrai 9/ 10 un vrai 9/ 10 bon
c'est pas mal on s'en sort pas trop mal
alors ce film ça s'appelle acide et
c'est juste Filippo qui vous a dirigé
dans ce film fil qui a été présenté déjà
à Cann en mai dernier vous accompagne
Laeticia doch et patience moodenbach et
le film est actuellement en sale il faut
y aller c'est puissant c'est sur la
forme sur le fond c'est intense c'est
extrêmement prenant en plus c'est une
j'allais dire une réalité imminente qui
pourrait là comme ça nous tomber dessus
au sens propre comme au sens figuré je
vous propose qu'on regarde ensemble la
bande annonce moi j'avoue j'ai été
secoué et on s'en parle après avec
plaisir
selon l'INR des pluies 1000 fois plus
acid que la normale ont été enregistré
on pas marre de ces merd là t'en fous la
planète c'est tout la fin du monde tous
les de jours de manière ça me concerne
plus que
toi pas grave on va la ramener à la
maison cha fois qu' pleutcide sulurique
corrosif pour la
peauux VO respirato et
dig 20partement vIIL r à la canicule du
jamais
[Musique]
vu 42 attend les ru de la
capitale vous êtes où là o
P pouvez allers
l'est c'est
quoi où est-ce qu'on va on va
où trouve une
maison je pas
d'hoire il aura pas
d'hoire tu confiance maintenant
[Musique]
est acide ce film dont vous êtes à la
fiche Guillaume Canet c'est c'est un
thriller singulier avec aussi une
histoire de famille alors moi au-delà
déjà de de ce sujet sur lequel
évidemment je vais vous répondre c'est
vrai que moi il y avait l'envie de
travailler avec Just Philippo qui donc
qui avait fait déjà un film qui
s'appelait la nuée et qui arrivé qui
avait déjà réussi de cette même manière
à mêler un un drame familial avec un un
film catastrophe c'estd que c'est c'est
tout son talent c'est de réussir à à
écrire une petite histoire dans la
grande c'est-à-dire que soit pas juste
un film
catastrophe climatique et tout ça il y a
il y a une histoire à l'intérieur de cet
homme qui est amoureux de cette femme
qui veut rejoindre en Belgique il est
retenu là à cause de sa son ex-fme et sa
fille qui a soudainement besoin de lui
et et retenu par le ciel qui lui tombe
sur la tête et je trouve que du coup
cette cette histoire intime à
l'intérieur est très très forte et
permet vraiment de de de d'avancer dans
cette toile de fond qui est le film
catastrophe climatique après la
catastrophe climatique c'est vrai que
les plus acides euh moi c'est vrai que
le sujet me touchait aussi parce que
parce que les plusu acides on en parle
depuis les années 80 c'est un sujet qui
est qui est réel en fait on a on a des
des pluies qui à cause à cause de
l'acide sulfurique qui a dans dans l'air
de la à cause de la pollution cré ces
plus acides et dévasse pour l'instant
des forêts qui
a blessé aussi des animaux mais mais
c'est resté c'est pas été au point de ce
que l'on voit dans le film maintenant si
la pollution venait à augmenter bah
c'est plus pourrait totalement exister
donc c'est quelque chose qui se passe
dans un futur imminent il y a aussi la
il y a aussi la prise de poids de musces
le défi physique vous êtes entraîné
ouais j'ai pris 9 kg 9 10 kg ouais ouais
ouais j'ai fait de la muscu j'avais
envie que ce personnage soit massif
parce que je trouvais intéressant que il
soit massif mais qu'il soit brisé parce
que on le voit au début du film il se
fait taper dessus par ces CRS et et il a
le dos en vrac il a il a une cicatrice
dans le dos et on comprend qu'il a sa
ceinture il a du mal à porter sa fille
et j'aimais cette idée d'un d'un d'un
animal blessé en fait et animal
blessé du coup qui est à vif en fait
violent à vif IR cible et et dangereux
en fait et dangereux par parce qu'il est
blessé et et donc j'aimais cette idée
c'est un ce côté un peu double de ce
personnage qui paraisse fort et qui
finalement ne l'est pas mais qui donne
une certaine violence quoi il y a
patience c'est la jeune fille vous en
êtes son papa c'est une ado alors
évidemment il y a aussi les
contradictions entre le regard qu'elle
elle porte sur le danger qui s'offre
enfin qui se présente et puis le le papa
qui est pas toujours présent donc là il
se recolle il se ressoude parce qu'il
faut affronter ses pluies acides
travailler avec cette jeune fille et
travailler avec cette sensibilité aussi
à fleur de peau c'était comment c'était
formidable elle était formidable
formable patience c'était assez étonnant
parce qu'au début moi quand j'ai lu le
scénario c'était une jeune fille de 8
ans et puis juste un gen m'a appel en me
disant j'ai trouvé ta fille elle est
formidable jeaais que tu la vois je suis
arrivé et je me suis retrouvé face à une
à une à une fille beaucoup plus é j'ai
pensé tout de suite au scènes où je
devais la porter sur le dos et mais mais
mais c'était formidable elle est elle
est elle était très très investi pendant
tout le tournage très très dans son
personnage qui n'est pas facile parce
que c'est un personnage qui est pas très
sympathique en fait qui qui est qui est
dans sa douleur de fille qui se sent
elle abandonnée face à un père qui lui
se sent abandonné par sa fille et son
ex-femme au moment où il a eu des
problèmes donc il y a une non
communication entre eux donc ça la rend
extrêmement du avec son père et avec
elle-même même et avec son entourage
elle est elle est à fleur de peau elle
aussi et et c'est toute la force de ce
film c'est tous ces personnages qui sont
à fleur de peau et qui se retrouvent
finalement ensemble coincés dans une
bagnole à fuir la pluie et et c'est vrai
que son personnage est est assez
complexe et elle elle elle l'a maîtrisé
je trouve formidablement bien quoi je me
souviens que vous aviez dit il y a
quelques années que Marcel notamment il
voulait pas voir vos films ça les
saoulait ouais là un film comme ça c'est
important pour vous de leur montrer
euh oui oui et non parce qu'en fait bon
d'abord il il sont sensibl j'imagine il
voit le film qu'il a envie de oui et
puis je pense qu'il a pas besoin de voir
ce film là pour être sensible sur la la
la cause aujourd'hui c'est des sujets
dont il parlent beaucoup à l'école entre
eux dont ils entendent parler à la à la
télé dans des dîners dans des dans des
donc c'est c'est quelque chose quand
même qui sont ils sont quand même très
investis les la génération d'aujourd'hui
en fait très très sensible à ça mais euh
mais non c'est vrai qu'il a il a du mal
à avoir les films de de ses parents ça
les saoule toujours ouais mais je peux
comprendre moi j'ai j'ai je peux
comprendre moi je suis pas un enfant euh
d' bal comme on dit je suis pas je suis
pas j'ai pas de mes parents qui étaient
dans ce métier mais je je peux
comprendre que ça puisse être compliqué
de et d'avoir envie que ses parents
restent ses parents en fait et de pas
voir forcément ses parents son père dans
un rôle d'un autre type euh voilà ça
commence à changer un petit peu parce
que il a envie de faire ce métier donc
finalement donc finalement il s'y
intéresse un petit peu plus mais j'ai
j'ai eu la chance de de réussir à le
convaincre cet été de lui montré mon
idole et et qui était mon premier film
parce que j'ai un pote qui était là
pendant les vacances et qui lui a parlé
du film et qui il voulait le revoir et
donc et donc ils l'ont vu et j'étais et
j'étais très heureux parce qu'il a
beaucoup aimé le film et du coup voilà
j'ai j'ai pu partager au moins mon mon
premier film alors il y a eu mon idole
bien sûr au premier film mais il s'est
passé quand même des choses avant et
nous on a envie remonter le fil ça
donnera peut-être des idées à Marcel
vous voulez bien vous installer avec le
crumble ou sans dans le fauteuil faute
qui est vers d'auville vers les planches
celui-là ouais tout à fait ouais euh la
télécommande est à droite le bouton
central ok je me mets comme chez le psy
comme ça comme chez un potes avec il
faut regarder un film voilà allons-y
tac ah
ouais donc vous avez retrouvé ces images
incroyable ça c'est
moin c'est mon premier court-métrage en
super h ENF un des premiers
court-métrages mais c'est celui que j'ai
fait vraiment avec Marine que vous voyez
là qui qui est voilà qui fait ses débuts
aussi avec Ti Peretti grand mteur en
scène à gauche et Jean-Marc Valenti un
autre pote avec qui j'étais au cour
Florent vous vous souvenez du titre le
film s'appelle sans regret
1996 voilà
et et en fait voilà c'est deux
personnages qui vont avoir une tournure
un peu particulière tout au long de leur
journée et voilà avec jéréy covillot
aussi qui était là c'était toute ma
bande de potes on faisait les traving au
au CAD au cad que vous avez vous avez
rendu ou pas après ah je sais pas où
est-ce CAD franchement je sais pas où il
est bon en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que vous avez été super précoce
Guillaume cané en à 12 ans quasiment 12
13 ans vous faites déjà des films en
super 8 ouis à 20 ans c'est un peu le
grand saut euh comment vous avez compris
euh que c'était le moment et que c'était
ça et rien d'autre en fait je l'ai
compris quand j'ai travaillé dans un
cirque et et en fait le le le weekend
parce que j'étais mineur donc on avait
pas le droit de faire des spectacles la
semaine et le weekend on avait on avait
le spectacle et j'avais un numéro avec
une planche avec un cylindre et je
jonglais sur cette planche en équilibre
et en fait les les premiers les premiers
applaudissements la première fin de
spectacle en fait après avoir répété
travaillé dans ce CIRC je me rappelle
dans les caravanes ils avaient
d'ailleurs des énormes sacs de de
biscuit euh en gros vous savez cétait
des biscuits comme ça je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai cette vision de du sac de
biscuit et en fait le
premier les
applaudissements fournis à la fin du
spectacle c'était c'était assez intense
et je pense que ça venait remplir un
besoin de reconnaissance un besoin
d'amour de de d'attention je pense et
qui m'a comblé et qui m'a donné envie de
faire quelque chose dans une branche
artisque
après je pense qu'il y avait la timidité
et l'envie de d'être plutôt derrière la
caméra et puis finalement bah je suis
passé le c'est ça en fait il y avait
quand même cette dualité ou en tout cas
cette richesse c'est vous de vouloir
regarder autant que d'être regardé ouais
ouais ouais bien sûr et je pense que
c'est pour c'est pour cette raison que
j'ai voulu faire les les les les deux en
fait je peux pas m'en passer en fait
j'ai besoin d'observer et d'être observé
et enfin pas d'être observé mais d'être
d'être d'être entendu ou d'être vu ouais
alors une autre image si vous voulez
bien appuyer
ouais une chose qui est sûre c'est que
si je l'attrape en premier on singler il
retendra jamais à
l'asile c'est chiant quoi de courir
après ces types comme un chass à cour je
vois pas ce que tu veux dire mais à
chaque fois on reçoit des coups de fil
et des lettres de ces fumiers alors
qu'on peut pas les coincer avant qu'ils
assassine la suivante et alors tu veux
laisser les flics le trouver avant nous
c'est ça j'ai pas dit ça je dis juste
que ça fait suer c'est
tout
jeer quelqu'un veut me la
teniris tout le monde de quoi tu
parles que ça te chierement ton bouot
une
choseis groupe je dis comme çaer taeule
dans C pourquoi tu t'énerves tu
cesnergie du groupe tuattraper avant les
poulets mais ça sera sans toi
je commence à me pomper l'air faut pas
m'avoir comme ennemi
ici 2014 cette fois la prochaine fois je
viserai le cœur de Cédric Anger vous
incarnez Franck un gendarme tueur qui
enquête sur ses propres affaires c'est
c'est un film tiré d'une histoire vraie
he l'affaire du du tueur de loise bon
c'est un rôle hor norme vous êtes nominé
au
César ce film cette performance cette ce
personnage c'est ça vous a marqué ouais
ouaticuliè ouais ouais complètement
c'est un personnage euh très très fort
j'ai eu la la cette chance que Cédric
Anger que j'aime beaucoup et dont j'aime
beaucoup le travail me m'offre ce ce
personnage euh j'étais euh j'étais
totalement habité par ce rôle en fait et
c'est vrai que j'ai même eu un peu de
mal à à à à en ressortir c'était un
personnage addtif ouais très prenant et
et je trouvais que c'était très bien
écrit et il y avait une ambiance dans ce
film entre la lumière la musique Cédric
avait réussi même sur le plateau à à
amener cette cette ambiance qu'on
ressent dans le film après et moi c'est
vrai que j'étais pour le coup j'avais
beaucoup maigri j'avais je m'étais
vraiment préparé pour ce personnage
j'avais lu vu beaucoup de choses sur ce
personnage sur l'histoire du tueur de
looise et c'est vrai que c'est un
personnage qui est qui est extrêmement
complexe et extrêmement intéressant ais
ça vous a fasciné je crois que vous vous
avvez enquêté un peu de votre côté hein
ouais ouais ouais ouais euh ce rôle il
est il est important aussi peut-être
dans d'un autre point de vue euh juste
avant il y a
l'expérience contrastée de Blood Ties
euh vous avez arrêté du coup de tourner
pendant une année et demi vous êtes
remonté à cheval vous avez douté à ce
moment-là euh ouais j'ai même décidé
d'arrêter de ce métier en fait euh j'ai
j'ai euh j'ai euh j'ai arrêté pendant un
an et demi je me suis remis à la
compétition à cheval et euh et je me
revois je suis
reparti d'ailleurs à un moment je suis
parti pendant je crois pratiquement un
mois en Espagne sur un faire des
concours internationaux je dormais dans
mon camion et tout c'était j'en avais
vraiment besoin en fait j'avais besoin
de ça j'avais besoin de de de prendre
l'air parce que j'avais
effectivement je sortais des des Petits
Mouchoirs où il y avait le film avait
rencontré un grand grand grand succès
moi j'avais pas forcément apprécié pu
apprécier ce succès parce que ça raconta
une histoire extrêmement personnelle et
le jour de la sortie j'ai perdu un pote
dans les mêmes conditions dans un
accident de moto et donc du coup j'ai
tout tout ça devenait assez salace en
fait pour moi et et et et euh et du coup
j'ai voulu tout reprendre à zéro et j'ai
fait un film qui correspondait au cinéma
qui m'a fait rêver le cinéma des années
70 et je suis parti faire ce film blood
TI aux États-Unis en reprenant un peu
tout à zéro puisque euh on a voilà j'ai
j'ai j'ai dans des conditions
financières bien différentes de Cell des
petits mouchoirs et c'est vrai que le
film n'a pas du tout marché
euh et et mais c'est un film que j'aime
énormément et dont je suis très très
fier et surtout je pense que j'étais à
une époque de ma vie où où où je donnais
beaucoup beaucoup trop en fait je
donnais beaucoup trop de ma vie de de
moi et que un moment j'avais peur de
devenir sec et je pense que j'ai eu ce
ce réflexe un peu instinctif de d'aller
me nourrir ailleurs alors justement une
autre image qui illustre vos propos
j'appuie
ouais quoi et tu trouves s le F ouais ça
va pour une fois que je me prends une m
je pas non plus vu par de million de
personnes on parle pour rien d'une
copelle de dring je le sais pas c'est
quoi ta prochaine idée de s'ingéner mais
check tes fesses mon homme parce que tu
vas te ramasser avec P mal plus qu' avec
tes plantes de
P oh ben coliss j'ai mon mod voyage ah
non mais c'est rien ça c'est c'est un
tatouage c'est regarde c'est un code
barre c'est pour dénoncer la société de
consommation parce que je sens bien
qu'ils essayent de faire de moi un
produit
ouis faut que tu comprennes j'ai plus
mal à ma couille tu comprends ce que ça
veut dire
tu vois l'expression j'en ai plein les
couilles ben moi regarde je me fais du
bien et j'ai plus mal aux couilles ça y
est même mon corps a compris que j'avais
compris ma couille a compris et moi je
suis
l'écoué 2017 très inspiré rock and roll
évidemment votre 5è long métrage
derrière la caméra nomination dans la
catégorie meilleur acteur bon bah c'est
c'est évidemment c'est savoureux c'est
une sorte de mise en abîme puisque vous
vous êtes vous-même Guillaume cané en
pleine crise de la quarantaine qui fait
tout pour rester désir able aussi bien
et B en fait puisque c'est aussi bien
sur le plan perso que le le plan
professionnel comment comment on part
dans ce dans cette état d'esprit dans
cette créativité là déjanté un peu
ouais je pense un ralbol qu'on qu'on
parle de de notre image de nous de de
notre vie sans rien savoir de notre vie
en fait et et c'est vrai que des fois
c'est assez amusant assez fou de voir ce
que les gens s'imagin de nous de savoir
si enfin de de de de la vie complètement
folle de star que apparemment on aurit
que qu'on a enfin voilà moi j'apprends
des trucs
euh sur sur des des maisons
qu'apparemment j'achète dans le
Sud-Ouest à des endroits trucs ENF des
trucs complètement fous et et il y a un
moment en fait il y a des moments où par
contre il y a des choses qui sont dites
et qui sont pas drôles et et et à un
moment je pense que j'ai j'ai eu un
certain ralbol et je me suis dit B bah
moi aussi je vais m'amuser alors avec ça
et tant qu'à faire autant que ça soit
moi et que et que je m'en amuse et que
j'aille dans dans ce que les gens
peuvent s'imaginer aussi et donc du coup
en fait faut pas croire tout ce que les
gens racontent et c'est ça que j'avais
envie de raconter aussi dans ce film en
fait et ça mort très bien puisque on
vous suit le public vous suit
complètement dans dans ce décalage en
fait ouais ouais et puis Marion est
extraordinaire elle a de jouer cette
autodérision complètement dingue de
faire cet accent québécois inoui
euh parce qu'elle fait le film de de LAN
et tout ça c'était c'était non non
c'était génial et puis on s'est vraiment
marré en le faisant on s'est vraiment
marré regardez derrière vous si vous
voulez bien faire un un petit demi-tour
sur vous-même vers la baie vitrée ouais
euh il y a une guitare encore encore
quoi ben non mais attendez mais à chaque
fois que je viens vous me demandez de
jouer de la guitare B non mais on a fait
dernière fois on a fait du
hobbyorse vous voulez refaire du hobby
ouais non mais j'ai pas joué de guitare
depuis une éternité alors attendez pour
vous chauffer je vous montre une image
et il y a du son qui va avec regardez à
droite j'habite la grande ville du mond
voà oui avec
Mathieu ça peut paraître
Juven et plus mon amour
vagabond aussi fatal U pour notre petit
nom le petit
n no petit
nombr la vie ne tient plus qu'à un
fil actualis qui pour V petit N
petit
n c'est votre pote a Mathie chedit bien
sûr qu'on adore qui a signé d'ailleurs
la Boo d'astérixé l'Empire du Milieu
toujours dispo sur Maike Cana les gros
cartons d'ailleurs là quand on est sur
scène avec son pote le Petit Nombril on
a l'impression que vous êtes un peu
enfin vous êtes en liberté quoi c'est là
il y a plus de contrôle je suis mort de
trouille non ah si si je suis mort de
trouille en fait Mathieu m'avait proposé
on en avait parlé de faire ça il m'avait
déjà fait cette chance enfin me donnerit
cette chance de chanter avec lui par
exemple aux arènes de nîes devant 17000
personnes et à chaque fois c'est
terrifiant je sais pas comment comment
ils font comment comment il fait bon
après il a un talent je pense que je
suis mort de cru parce que j'ai pas du
tout ce talent et que et que voilà mais
moi c'est vrai que j'étais terrifié je
chante comme un canard c'est un K absolu
non mais c'est un K absol non mais après
après on a une on a une bouffée de
d'énergie avec des gens alors il a la
chance Mathieu d'avoir un public
extraordinaire extrêmement chaleureux
donc c'est moi qui a eu cette chance là
de de me retrouver face à ce public qui
m'a qui m'a donné des ailes et il y
avait pas de jugement et et ça ça leur
faisait plaisir que je sois là avec mon
pote et que je chante avec lui mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas pour mes
talents de bah vous chantez juste en
tout cas et là vous ayez ça vous Titi
alors allez-y non non je je jou comme ça
que M
[Musique]
demand je sais pas quoi
jouer cette séquence va êre reprise de
partout et tout m de
maeule
pour vous remercier parce que vous avez
joué le jeu et c'est super sympa j'ai un
truc à vous offrir ouais mais pas
n'importe quoi dites-moi derrière vous
dans le l'angle du canapé ouais
wou génial alors attendez attendez de
l'avoir
ouvert génial alors il faut expliquer
évidemment parce que vous êtes un fan
inconditionnel de Jean-Paul bmondo et ça
c'est le professionnel 1981 avec donieu
Bernard pierre ouais ouais ou il vient
lui manger croissant et lui mettre une
grande tarte dans la
gueule vous avez fait cette coupe de
cheveux je crois ouais j'allais avec
j'ai vu le poster quelque part non c'est
le laffiche là du du le DVD qui est
là-bas là du professionnel ouais
j'allais chez chez le coiffeur quand
j'étais gamin avec l'affiche j'avais
uneaffiche du film du professionnel mais
en grand et je la roulais je l' enleva
punaise et j'allais et je l' emmenais en
fait chez le coiffeur et je lui montrais
la laaffiche et je lui demandais de
faire fa exactement la même coupe de
cheveux et après je reroulais ma mon
affiche et j'allais à repunaiser dans
dans ma chambre et ouais j'étais
absolument totalement fan de Jean-Paul
et et bah j'ai toujours été et j'ai eu
la chance effectivement de passer du
temps avec lui et de de le rencontrer de
faire quelques dîner quelques déjeuner
avec lui et et et j'ai j'ai une
affection très très particulière pour
lui pour son ami Jean rochfort qui est s
mon père spirituel et et c'est vrai que
j'ai eu des moments incroyables cette
anecdote que j'ai déjà raconté mais
peut-être vou je la raconteès rapidement
mais j'étais le voir au théâtre dans la
puce à
l'oreille avec Christiana ralii et il
ouvre un moment une enveloppe qui était
censé être une enveloppe de sa maîtresse
et là il l'ouvre et moi j'étais apprenti
comédien j'avais pas fait grand-chose
j'étais avec un pote au théâtre en train
de le voir et là il ouvre la lettre et
il la referme tout de suite et sa femme
christianal lui dit qu'est-ce que c'est
il fait oh c'est le jeune cané et donc
donc moi je suis comme ça dans la salle
pétrifié je regarde mon pote je
comprends pas et et elle dit quoi le
jeune cané fait oh rien il veut faire
l'acteur et donc là j'étais complètement
halluciné je comprenais pas du tout ce
qui se passait et à la sortie à la fin
il y a quelqu'un qui est venu me
chercher en me disant il y a Monsieur
Belmondo qui vous attend dans sa loge et
je suis arrivé il est arrivé alors la
surprise vous a plu et et en fait c'est
Rochefort qui lui avait dit parce que je
commençais barracoua avec rochfort et
qui lu avait dit que je venais voir le
voir au théâtre et ils lu ont fait ils
m'ont fait une blague voilà et c'était
euh la rencontre avec Jean-Paul ça reste
gravé évidemment merci pour l'anecdote
savoureuse euh nous évidemment on va
vous laisser repartir avec votre avec
votre merci beaucoup pour ce cadeau euh
merci d'avoir joué merci d'avoir joué le
jeu euh on vous retrouve évidemment dans
les salles obscures je vais venir vous
est-ce que vous pouvez doubler ma voix
quand je chante est-ce que vous pouvez
mettre la voix
d'AB ça peut être pas mal on va voir ce
qu'on peut faire comme
montage merci Guillaume Canet merci
beaucoup d'être venu jusqu'à nous ça
s'appelle acide c'est dans les salles
obscures juste Filippo signe ce film
avec cette atmosphère avec cette
pesanteur avec cette Tréal qui est ouais
qui est assez forte intense vraiment
vraiment intense donc allez-y ouais il
est très très doué franchement c'est un
un grand grand metteur en scène et et
c'est pas voilà c'est un grand spectacle
je sais que les gens restent accrochés à
à leur fauteuil et c'est et très
réaliste de surcroix réaliste et prenant
c'est ce que je dirais en conclusion si
vous me l'autorisez merci merci à vous
je suis très heureux ou je chanter
plus je reste qu'avec ce goût de
pourquoi j'ai chanté pour r ave pH coup
al j'urais pu faire des accords mais
sans chanter oh mais si c'est ça le
lâcher prise non ouaisy j'ai pas encore
réussi totalement je vous
embreent